essere a trento come sarà hollywood
incredibile pensate di essere stati
influenzati dai cartoni animati cioè dai
film di animazione che avete visto da
bambini avete mai sognato di essere un
super eroe invincibile una fata
affascinante o un mago esuberante o
forse di volare verso l'isola che non
c'è provate a immaginare e se potessimo
usare l'animazione non solo per
permettere bambini di tuffarsi immondi
incredibile fantastici ma anche per
trasportarli in mondi reali diversi nei
loro mondi che a volte possono incutere
timore o anche paure paure si paura del
diverso del cambiamento paura
dell'ignoto e se con la magia
dell'animazione potessimo sconfiggere
queste paure avvicinare così le culture
e superare le barriere e delle diversità
culturali
probabilmente state pensando che sia una
pazza visionaria ma torniamo bambini
solo per un attimo
chiudete gli occhi per piacere solo per
un secondo
pensate al vostro primo cartone animato
andata indietro con la memoria quale era
quel film quanto vi emozionati e quanto
via coinvolti
io penso che in questo momento abbiate
un idea molto vivida di un'immagine e
penso che sia una memoria collegata tale
un periodo dei vostri primi dieci anni
si ritiene infatti che i primi dieci
anni siano fondamentale per la
formazione di un individuo quello che
vivete ma soprattutto quello che provate
le emozioni durante questo periodo
disegnano avrei portati dentro tutta la
vita e allora mi sono detta ma se si
potesse andare al di là della storia
della principessa che bacia una rara del
coyote che segue un uccello o della fata
dei desideri
se si potesse con l'animazione parlare
anche di storie diverse
potremo così influenzare i bambini prima
delle dieci anni prima che siano
completamente formati come individui e
potremo portare loro messaggi di
coraggio di cambiamento i forti valori
morali e culturali
c'era una volta un bambino siriano che
sognava di essere ballerino nel suo
paese ma forzato dalla guerra è stato
costretto a realizzare il suo sogno
altrove c'era una volta una bambina
afghana innamorata della musica e contro
ogni opinione è riuscita non solo
diventare musicista ma anche a diventare
la direttrice della prima orchestra
afghana composto da sole donne
c'era una volta un bambino del malawi
che grazie alle sue invenzioni riesce a
portare l'elettricità per la prima volta
nel suo villaggio sperduto
insomma storia importante storie di
piccoli grandi eroi che devono essere
raccontate devono essere portate ai
nostri figli
e perché no con la magia dell'animazione
e qui lasciatemi raccontare una storia
la mia come molte di voi nel pubblico
sicuramente siete cresciuti con storie
di guerra
mia nonna era una bambina nella prima
guerra mondiale e mia mamma poi
sopravvisse la seconda di tutte le
storie che mia mamma mi ha raccontato
quello che più mi ha segnato che più mi
è rimasta dentro e quella cui mi
descriveva come si sentiva da bambina
sotto i bombardamenti proprio qui a
trento andava mila senza forza bloccato
dalla paura che non riusciva a scappare
e allora mia mamma più che una storia
riuscita a farmi capire come un bambino
si possa sentire nel mezzo di un
conflitto è riuscita a trasmettere quel
suo indelebile ricordo
un'angoscia un'angoscia che forse
possiamo cercare di capire con guardando
foto come questa
lo sappiamo bene purtroppo che questa
non è la prima e non sarà nemmeno
l'ultima e se non si fa qualcosa se non
ci impegniamo la storia continua a
ripetersi ma infatti quando avevo 20
anni ed ero al mio primo corso di
animazione scoppiò la guerra dei balcani
e in quel momento tutte le storie
raccontate mida mia doppia mamma che
erano rimasta nel mio cuore e nella mia
mente non erano più così lontane e in
quel momento decisi e mi ripromisi che
quando mi sarei sentita pronta avrei
usato l'arte che adoro e che amo
l'animazione per agire e cercare di fare
una differenza e dopo anni passati nel
mondo dell'animazione internazionale
capi caro pronta per scrivere dirigere
il mio primo film sapevo esattamente di
cosa avrei voluto parlare c'era una
volta una bambina a trento sotto i
bombardamenti si chiamava mila
mi rivolsi con entusiasmo a tutti gli
studi e grandi studi ma ben presto capi
che questi studi non erano interessati a
parlare di storie socialmente impegnate
queste storie non erano adatte al loro
business e nessuno voleva investire in
un cartone animato che parlasse di
guerra fu una pillola difficile da
digerire ma come forse sapete tante
volte dal rifiuto può nascere la forza e
così decisi di non accettare quel no e
allora mi rivolgo i miei amici e
colleghi e la loro risposta fu
incredibile il desiderio di mettere in
evidenza la tragedia dei bambini vittime
di guerra ma non solo di parlare in
generale ed i temi forti con un
linguaggio dolce e più accessibile
bambini ci ha uniti e oggi il mila team
conta di più di 350 artisti che
collaborano volontariamente da 35 paesi
alcuni dei quali purtroppo nel mezzo di
conflitti e questo è un esempio del
nostro lavoro
[Musica]
come vi è sembrato troppo forte per i
bambini
io penso di no
io penso che purtroppo sottostimiamo i
bambini i bambini hanno fondamento e
curiosa hanno la mente aperta sono
liberi da pregiudizi e riescono così a
processare le cose in modo diverso da
noi
questa meravigliosa forma d'arte
l'animazione è stata purtroppo limitata
inscatolata in genere cinematografico ed
è ora di aprire questa scatola e
permettere ai registi agli artisti agli
story teller di portare al grande
pubblico anche un altro tipo di
animazione l'animazione non ha limiti e
sul mercato in costante crescita
ma quanto grande e questo mercato
dall'animazione vediamo un attimo
l'animazione in modo particolare dei
lungometraggi questi sono dati basati su
lungometraggi usciti negli stati uniti e
quindi con una diffusione una
distribuzione mondiale qui vedete negli
ultimi 30 anni praticamente lo sviluppo
del mercato dell'animazione in grigio ci
sono quello che rappresentano il budget
e il ritorno agli introiti dei grandi
fine grandi studi cioè con molto budget
di sheen commerciali quelli che andate
solitamente a vedere al cinema con i
vostri figli i vostri nipoti e il rosso
in basso molto inverso come vedete i
film indipendenti che hanno dei budget
limitatissimi rispetto a quelli
commerciali purtroppo possiamo anche
vedere poi la l'enorme differenza che
c'è nell'animazione al minuto questo
sono le spese al minuto per ogni film di
animazione
in media un film commerciale raggiunge
il milione milione e mezzo minuto invece
tre i film indipendenti purtroppo hanno
solamente poche decine di migliaia di
dollari a disposizione per minuto
contate che il il business
dell'animazione ha raggiunto l'anno
scorso quasi 7 miliardi di dollari è in
costante crescita e parlo solamente di
lungometraggi non parliamo nemmeno di
televisione e poi un altro aspetto molto
importante per il nostro business che la
distribuzione perché se non si hanno
sale quando escono i film durante il
primo weekend nessuno andrà a vedere i
nostri film ovviamente film commerciali
hanno solo a me di solito hanno a
disposizione 2.500 3.000 sali di media
con dei picchi di quasi 5mila a seconda
degli studi chiaramente come vedete
sotto il rosso devo dire la verità che
ho dovuto aumentare il rosso perché sono
le nuove date per i film indipendenti
sono una manciata di sale del sicuro
l'anno scorso suonata a vedere un
bellissimo film di animazione
indipendente e le scelte erano los
angeles new york una sala un giorno
purtroppo la questi dati penso che
capiate le potenzialità di un
lungometraggio di animazione ogni anno
centinaia di artisti di registi riescono
a fare a produrre i loro cortometraggi e
sono spessissimo trattano temi forti
importanti culturalmente diversi ma
purtroppo sono destinati solamente al
festival per cui con un'audience di
nicchia raggiungono poche persone alcuni
riescono a fare anche nei lungometraggi
pro poi come avete visto non hanno
distribuzione
e allora cosa possiamo fare per cambiare
le cose
non ci resta che fare una rivoluzione la
rivoluzione del fare
fidati agisci rischia esplora
ma questa rivoluzione non può partire
solo da noi dagli addetti ai lavori
dagli artisti degli animatori dove
partire da tutti noi
io spero che nel futuro i grossi studi
di animazione decidono di investire
anche in film che sono socialmente
diversi con temi impegnati quale miglior
mezzo sono l'animazione per portare i
nostri figli
storie diverse che li arricchiscono che
possono eliminare queste barriere
culturali avvicinarci tutti un pochino
di più e forse sperare insieme in un
mondo migliore
se siete un produttore e vedete una
storia fantastica che vi entusiasta non
pensate subito a quanto farà ai
botteghini
seguite il vostro cuore date in una
possibilità se siete un distributore
offrite a questi film nelle sale
abbiate fiducia nel vostro pubblico
roma non è stata creata in un giorno
tutte le cose hanno bisogno di tempo non
solo per essere fatte ma anche per
essere create e soprattutto è la cosa
più importante
se siete genitori come lo sono io
scegliete film di animazione con la
stessa cura con cui scegliete il cibo
buono per i vostri figli e se non l'hai
trovato a disposizione richiede temi
fatevi sentire
vi assicuro che la forza e con voi siete
voi che decidete dovete farvi sentire
dai distributori dai produttori dai
grandi studi e tutti insieme potete
cambiare le cose
potete partecipare a creare un mondo
migliore come dicevamo walt disney
l'unico modo per riuscire a cambiare le
cose e smettere di parlare e agire
grazie
[Applauso]